hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast
I'm your host Sean Carroll and as I've
said before one of the major motivations
for me personally in doing a podcast
project is to be able to explore things
other than what I do for a living mostly
physics a little bit of philosophy so
the podcast lets me talk to other
scientists neuroscientist biologists
chemists and also it lets me go beyond
science we've talked to poker players
and movie directors and musicians and so
forth so today's podcast is definitely
one of those examples of going well
beyond my comfort zone go Wong
today's guest is actually a computer
scientist officially a computer
programmer at Stanford University and
that's my comfort zone okay but his
specialty is computer programming of
music so he build instruments that make
computers into musical instruments he
puts on performances with laptop
orchestras things like that go on has a
famous TED talk where he demonstrates an
iPhone ocarina you can actually if you
have an iPhone go to the App Store
download an app called ocarina which
will turn your iPhone into a musical
instrument you don't need any extra
hardware you blow into the microphone
and make beautiful music will actually
have a demonstration on the podcast
today however God wrote a book that was
not about computer programming or
musical instruments but about the
general idea of design artful design
designing anything whether it's
computers and musical instruments but
cups of coffee or pencil boxes or
anything like that the general
principles that relate form and function
the human needs and the possibilities of
the technology or of the shapes you're
doing whether it's music or art or
industrial design I know nothing about
this I think it's a cool and important
topic so we had a great conversation but
this is definitely an example where
we're learning new things you know I
bring no special predilections or
pre-existing notions to this
conversation and therefore we had a lot
of fun design is everywhere in our lives
and thinking about it with someone who
is also an expert in computer science
and music was a great experience so
let's go
[Music]
go on thanks for coming on the mindscape
podcast thanks John thanks for having me
now all I'm gonna admit right away that
this is going to be one of the more
adventurous podcasts that I've done
you've written a book about design which
is something I know nothing about not
like even when I know nothing about
things like neuroscience or whatever
I still have opinions about them and
here's something I don't even have
opinions about so hopefully we'll have a
wide-ranging conversation and you'll be
able to guide me through the rough spots
and so forth but let's start with the
fact that in some sense you're a
computer programmer you're computer
scientist is that a fair thing to say
that is a fair thing to say my PhD in
undergrad were both in computer science
even though now I'm an associate
professor in the music department
actually in the center for computer
research and music and acoustics CCRMA
or karma Stanford but that's in within
the music department so within the music
department called a courtesy appointment
in computer science so I'm kind of
really ever kind of both places and
neither places I obviously don't know
what I am exactly but I think it's fair
to say I'm a computer scientist it's the
best place to be not knowing where you
are but you have to get to not knowing
where you are I mean did the computer
interest come first or the music
interest you know at some point those
were both interesting because I loved
building things and I think the computer
science eventually spoke directly to
that I could I can really realize things
that I wanted to see how this works ER
and then I always been always loved
music it's just the state you grow up at
playing instruments I grew up playing
accordion it's age seven hard core and
then my grandma in my my grandparents
got me dad and my parents got me an
electric guitar for my 13th birthday and
that changed my world are you one of
these people because I know some people
like they're handed an instrument they
never played it before and like within
minutes
beautiful music is coming out and I
haven't completely the opposite of that
I don't know I don't know about
beautiful music but I love just playing
instruments figuring out how they
actually interact and how they work and
yeah something some sounds will likely
come out behind me an instrument it
might not be beautiful and it's at some
point I mean when did you realize that
that the computer side of things could
have a musical component Lily towards
the end of undergrad it was I mean I was
taking music classes to computer science
classes and then then I took a class at
Duke because where did my undergrad from
professor Scotland Roth who's actually
now the vice provost of the arts at Duke
and he's a you know he's I think he's
been a lifelong mentor and I took this
computer music class and I heard music
that was just like I didn't hear
anywhere else and felt and realized I
couldn't really hear anywhere else
except in the medium of the computer and
that fascinated me were you already a
computer science major at that yeah oh
sorry computer science major okay cool
and so then you go to your PhD and like
help write programming languages and
things like that yeah so uh I think
having had that experience with like
electronic music computer music
undergrad I applied to grad school in
computer science but really kind of
looking for programs that did computer
music and I was very fortunate to find
well my advisor Perry cook at Princeton
used in computer science but it also was
jointly appointed at Princeton in music
so he's actually was Princeton's first
joint hire across engineering in arts
and humanities that's very difficult to
do I know yeah yeah and so I ended up
working on things like yeah programming
language for generating music it's
called Chuck the working animal count
laptop orchestras but writing a
programming language that just sounds
very hardcore like are you in there is
it a assembly language heading right a
programming language or do you write it
in a different language and then compile
it um so Chuck was written in C++ and
the way I wrote it was allah took a
compiler class and then i basically well
it's I followed basically chapter by
chapter this textbook on how to
basically how to make a compiler and
look at Hamming languages by Andrew
Appel who happened to be another
professor at Princeton at the time and
and and I literally I knew nothing about
human language so I literally just
followed the textbook but then I
deviated when I when I needed to and I
think I've designed it really backwards
the design it backwards I think and I
mean then a good way in that I kind of
wrote down on paper the kind of code I
want
- right and I wanted and to get the kind
of music I want so kind of fit you know
what I want this thing look like and now
I went back and see if I can actually do
it by writing code to kind of implement
these are you telling me that form
follows function sometimes yes fun often
follows functions sometimes function
follows form in a weird way it's who was
the guy who said that first it was there
your architect Louis Sullivan who is
Sullivan okay yes yeah and of course
it's he's trying to make a point but in
reality like you say there are two
things form and function that go back
and forth and so this is is it is it
safe to say that designing this computer
programming language is one of the first
ways you came into contact with that
principle yeah I mean I didn't really
think to to intentionally consciously
about design at the time I just wanted
to build things it was actually my
advisor Perry cook we said this cryptic
thing to me and say you know go whatever
you whatever you make I mean whatever
you do do it with aesthetics and I was
like I have no idea what that means
computer science major right but it
obviates sense and Perry still denies
that he's ever said this here's and
remember he actually said this me but
like I was like this completely changed
the way I I do things and things are not
just pure functional things we are not
purely functional creatures but we we
actually you know you say that you don't
you don't know anything about design but
I would beg to differ and I think we all
we all have and cannot help them make
aesthetic judgments for things you know
what's not just what's pleasing but
what's beautiful
what's truthful what's just and what's
just plain awesome these are all I think
aesthetic judgments well that's good I
mean that's what I want to get into that
at some point but let me just back up a
little bit because despite being a
computer scientist but despite having a
appointment in a music department yes
you didn't write a book about computer
music did there's computer music in
there but you wrote you code a grander
palette right the aim for bigger fish
yes I think so artful design i well i
took me three years to write it and
I still don't know exactly what it's
about elite or anymore I thought I did
it has a lot of computer music in there
but I think it tries to address you know
three questions and and you know I would
say they are you know what is the nature
of design and the median holds human
life what does it mean to design well
into design ethically and and how can
this shaping of technology reflect our
values as human beings so those are kind
of these broader questions I tried to
tackle yeah yeah a very
interdisciplinary and also you know very
grand but like you say everyone has some
kind of design sense right I mean like I
say for scientists sometimes degrading
philosophy I always tell them look you
can't not do philosophy you can do it
well or you could do it badly I didn't
if you're not educated that maybe you do
it badly and maybe design is the same
way I love that I think that's high
personal II think that's absolutely
right is that you just you know whatever
you I think design is really you have an
outcome or something in mind and you go
about very intentionally shaping or
changing things to kind of achieve that
outcome you're kind of putting the
pieces together making them fit to
actually you know get at some result or
for a certain purpose and when you do
that you're designing and at what point
did you go from you know you have been
designing a course computer programming
languages and we'll get into actual
musical instruments and orchestras and
so forth but what is it that made you
think that the book you should write
should be about the idea of design
rather than about these more specific
examples of it that's a good question
I think a couple couple of things for
what for one I I think I was realizing
what I was doing was liking it's like
engineering it's like art but it's also
not like engineering exactly not like
art exactly right it embodies
engineering precision you do need to
really get to the nuts and bolts of you
know how you program or how you do
software engineering or how certain
technique or technology actually works
you know and you build hardware things
as well right and from time to time I'm
mostly a software guy but sometimes I
dabble in hardware as well
and in like art it's there's a certain
artfulness you can definitely bring into
things you engineer not just in how it
looks but kind of you know how it
actually works in does the way of
working actually reflect something you
want it to reflect these more I think
tacit and intangible qualities of and
something that we clearly care about you
know if you just look at buildings right
people design buildings and if we just
cared about the function we all be
content living in warehouses and clearly
we're not so I think that we know to do
you think about buildings in that way
but you know I think when it comes to
things like software tools games social
experiences these are I think we're just
learning to think about more
aesthetically yeah about these things in
it it reminds me a little bit I
interviewed scott derrickson the movie
director for the podcast and I was
remarking to him that you know I I'm
very happy with books and words and
pages and also equations and figures and
other physics see things so I could
imagine in an alternate life being like
a movie screen writer or a novelist or
something like that I couldn't imagine
being a director because there's a
million other things that to worry about
like that personalities of the actors
but also the design of the sets and the
costumes and everything and he and he
said which sort of the obvious answer
but you know that's what he likes he
likes the fact that there's a little bit
of everything involved and it sounds
like you were drawn to the fact that you
were a computer programming but in a way
that you know given that it was music
and instruments and so forth design just
became a necessary element pretty
obviously yeah and I think that's right
and if felt like design is really this
universal thing that we all do but only
more you know recent times that we do we
think about design and as kind of a
discipline or a thing onto itself but I
think we've always designed we can't
help but design but I think it more like
anything else it's it's also possible to
do well or do poorly right and I I'm
really interested in how we can think
about doing it well or doing it better I
mean obviously Archimedes or Leonardo or
designers even though they wouldn't have
called themselves that right so it's it
I mean is is it true or
just fooling ourselves to think that
there is a separate discipline called
design right yeah we design so many
different things from music - you know
teapots right and are there common
principles there I that's a wonderful
question I think I like to think that
the design shouldn't be its own actually
separate discipline actually I think
it's just something that all of us do
and there's a certain universality I
think that actually does pervade design
really everywhere I awful design I think
I try to offer a few of them one is this
idea that I you know in looking at the
motivation you know design is all about
purpose it's like what are you trying to
do and and then how are you gonna go
about doing it and I would also add why
would you want to do that so there's all
these different dimensions that I think
that's common to any design and and then
part of this why I you know I break it
down into this inter means versus ends
and what I mean by that it means as it
means to an end
like I do this because I want to achieve
some of the purpose you know I'm hey I'm
gonna make this thing to open it can for
me right so that's that's a means to an
end but in it end in itself that's the
other side are kind of the more
intrinsically interesting or valuable or
beautiful things about a design a form
would fit into that this is the idea we
don't all live in warehouses exactly
we've been in aesthetically pleasing
space yeah please think but also places
things to with meaning
you know buildings aren't just pleasing
it's great when they are right but also
you know buildings can serve as kind of
symbols can serve as meaning for the for
the people or this even the city that
it's in and and also I I think there's a
soon well for lack of a better word
truth that we can get at when we
actually design things you know okay and
it's something that reflects who we are
in kind of our values and I think that
all from that from a is all kind of
indeed this aesthetic dimension of
design so there is certainly this this
idea that let's make things look really
look and feel good but
I think it actually goes much deeper
than that and that we can you know that
it's a tool even if you're building a
tool you know it's a tool making
people's lives better does it speak to
your well being and and what are the
values that actually that's actually a
play here yeah I think that this is I
mean because like I said since I'm not
an expert and I have no prior experience
to the formal aspects of this way of
thinking I was trying to you know
struggle with how to even grasp what the
essence of design was supposed to be
there is an aesthetic component
obviously but it's not just hanging art
on your wall it is a functional aspect
of things right and so at the trivial
level there's this marriage between
doing things or having things done for
purpose and having them aesthetically
pleasing but what you're pointing at is
that there's like I'm not sure if it's
another dimension or or an extra
movement in the same direction of
meaningfulness and you know some
connection with what it means to be
human is reflective in the best design I
think that's exactly right I think it's
this meaning you know it can
there's dr. a principle in the book that
as she was talking about AI and
automation and I think the principle is
a two-part one it says you know that
which can be automated should be
automated except where in cases were you
know if something is cannot be
meaningfully automated it should not be
automated so I'll give you an example
the Ottoman yeah what's an example well
for example this act of playing to play
like I like well like playing hopefully
right and to play like I don't it does
not matter how well I play I just want
to play and I don't ever want that
automated because the whole point of
plane is to do it yourself right right
you want to build a computer program to
play your video games for you exactly
and and all these you know a lot of
things that are will experience you'll
for example it's meaningful for us to do
and it's and certainly I can have like a
program or robot kind of play in my
place but what's the point of that you
know it's possible but not meaningful
and is some level I think this you know
for all the automation that that's
coming into our world with technology
I think humans at some level still have
to be the arbiters of meaning you know
we have to determine what is meaningful
to do and you know what do we want to
what do we want to do and that gets back
to this question of you know what's
intrinsically interesting about you know
certain activities well good so we have
time here so let's let's unpack this a
little bit because I've had philosophers
on the podcast and will and you know one
of them Alex Rosenberg who I recently
talked to you know kind of is skeptical
about the idea of meaning at all but I
think he's an extremist on one side so
let's go the other side like what what
do you mean
meaning what is it what is that is it
just I care about that or is there
something deeper do you personally delve
into the philosophical literature when
thinking about these things
not meaning per se but I do delve into
some philosophical literature I think
the meaning is really like for me it's
actually something simple in this and
not in the and not simplistic but simple
in the sense I think it is what we value
okay it's and the meaning is you know if
it's if it's meaningful to you that
means you find some value that hmm and I
was saying more inwardly rewarding kind
of a value okay that's the meaning more
bling more more money or with it right
it's not the not soul exactly it's more
like your soul and in a play for example
I think is a good example of like this
is it matters to me you may not matter
anybody else but that value of play is
so fundamental to it it's it's it's a so
something that speaks to this value of
play is meaningful to me in that sense
so I think it's interesting to think
about why play exists right why through
the process of natural selection this
came to be I mean I have cats I grew up
with dogs certainly other animals are
very playful in their own right it does
it serve some function or is that is
that is it just an offspring of other
things that are useful well it's it I've
thought about that a lot I have no no
clear answers on that but it leads me to
think about other things like food and
eating right I think it's a related
thing to play like eating and one hand
is very functional right we we we eat so
we sustain ourselves so we
and don't die but clearly we've we're at
a point where we also eat for its sheer
enjoyment and I think there's in this
one thing we find we actually have this
dual purpose if you you know one it's
very functional one is very aesthetic
and we clearly spend a lot of time and
energy thinking about and going about
like making food making sure there is
food and you know really cooking is an
art right so I sometimes I wonder if
like you know mmm where our statics
actually come from the aesthetic of play
the aesthetic food the aesthetic of
freely if finding things beautiful or
truthful and do they arise from kind of
tradition you know evolutionarily more
functional things I don't have I'm not
an expert in yes I I don't know if I can
offer a good answer on this but I think
about this all the time is I like where
does this it's remarkable to me that
that we can experience things at right
period you know like and it's remarkable
that we find things beautiful and even
if we knew the answer to the question of
where it came from was it wouldn't
change the fact meaningful right I often
end some of my talks when I talk about
the big picture of the book that I wrote
there's a lot of sort of deflationary
messages you know we're bags and atoms
we live for a very short period of time
we're small compared to the universe but
then you show a picture of the universe
the Hubble ultra-deep field with all
these galaxies and the point is we took
that picture right like we decided to
spend millions and millions of dollars
to take that picture and it's not
helping us feed ourselves or anything
like that we just wanted we had the
curiosity and the interest in the beauty
that was brought out to that that's
exactly right and and you know
fundamental research like you know
theoretical physics it's for me it's I
think of it more less like science and
engineering but more as really it's like
the humanities in a way right it's
really getting at some fundamental truth
of about the world it's in like with a
capital W or every what is there yeah
and also our place in it and it's so
human to want to
to want to understand like that you know
yeah I just agree I don't tell my talk
my colleagues I'm saying this but it
does have a lot to do with you know the
humanities it's driven by curiosity not
by immediate practical interests but as
you point out you know even the areas of
discipline where you study that are
driven by immediately practical
interests engineering biology medicine
they still have this aesthetic component
so maybe let's come back ground
ourselves a little bit you you got here
through this journey of music and
computers and so forth so tell us about
some of the design you've done in that
arena yourself you know the making of
different kinds of musical instruments
orchestras and so on
sure I've I make tools toys games and
social experiences with technology from
for musical purposes and I can give you
a demo of one if you like I would love
it them have the awesome so this is a
this is an app I designed
10 years ago I started a company called
Smule as Smule is still around and it's
a way to make music
socially together with people I I
stepped down five years ago but Smule is
still going strong
but designed this as part of you mule
tenures gonna its ocarina and it's it's
an app for your for your phone you play
it by blowing into it so I took it
before you play it is it coming out of
that speaker yes okay so we should put
that in front of the microphone okay so
how directional is a pretty darn
directional so yeah so let's try the
Edit you have me edit part of this out
now really this end we're gonna all the
messiness is here we this yeah brought
more paraphernalia than any other
podcast guest I've had so far so this is
awesome so uh I'm holding my phone by
not in the usual way I'm kind of holding
it like a sandwich and I'm blowing into
the microphone the bottom
and I'm using my fingers on the screen -
they're these four circles that expands
contract when I when I press down on
them and those control pitch
accelerometer in the iPhone controls by
barato so if I hold the phone flat
versus tilting it downward that's
vibrato you can play all kinds of little
ditty with this and it's it it's a very
physical use of the phone and you
haven't there's no hardware enhancement
to the phone you didn't put a you know
pick up or anything like that it how
does your blowing on the phone get
registered so I'm blowing to the
microphone in there there's actually a
soft little software program that's
tracking the strength of how hard and
blowing into the microphone you know
even blew the microphone I'm not gonna
do it here but yeah we get to and from
there you can just basically do an
envelope follower and see how much
roughly how much Energy's in there and
then you map that to sound that's being
generated on on the device okay and and
that's that's pretty much it and then
you're mapping the interaction from the
multi-touch and the accelerometer and to
different parameters in the sound
synthesis and this is called ocarina cuz
it is very much like good existing
instrument called the ocarina right this
is an inner stream that's been around in
various forms for thousands of years
actually and it's one of the more I
would say than the simpler instruments
to start playing because the interaction
really is you know you blow into and
there's a few holes you can hold down
inking to control pitch and to answer
your earlier question yeah this is no no
add-ons to the phone the part of the
design was didn't say can we design
something that required those or the
constraints that require no additional
components and in a way and I talked
about this in artful design this is
inside out design this is actually
function following a bit of form and the
form in this case being your phone yeah
you have a phone
we didn't do with it what all the things
that's on the phone and and what makes
sense and if you go through this
exercise like well a piano is like a
little too big and interaction you know
hover keys you have a gate keys and or
guitar or drums these are all but a
four-hole English pendant ocarina is
about the same size as the as the iPhone
and also the complexity of interaction
is comparable about the same yeah so
that was kind of rematch
he's a perfect match and it's this
backwards like you know I say we design
backwards from relief the end users
experience and we design backwards from
the medium in this case the medium was
the iPhone and all the things that it's
available but you had in mind you number
one you wanted to make a musical
instrument yes number two you had an
iPhone available and so and our
listeners can go download this on the
App Store
yeah ocarina is available look for Smeal
ocarina and in actually there's another
component to offer as well okay this is
a social component there's a logo
visualization
and here I'm actually seeing this double
helix graphics coming out of actually
display Southern California playing Ode
to Joy nope someone who calls himself to
a belted biscuit built it best is this
person that I know I've no idea a
classic an undiscovered genius out there
across the street you wouldn't know
right doesn't matter
yeah but you know roughly where they're
coming from here amazing grace from it's
like London atom and that's all you know
about you know who these people are the
APUs was designed free not to what's a
weird social network so it's basically
all that's doing is other people are
playing and we can listen to whatever
they're playing yeah that's all in all
of this when I play it that means they
can listen to me when you're playing
your bed well the app is kind of taking
in these little snippets and then you
turn action and sending those up to
basically a server and then that's you
when someone's listening they kind of
randomly get served something in the
recent past okay so it's not quite in
real time and not quite in real time you
know so this morning when I was just
trying to make it work at all and not
really completely succeeding that is not
probably sense to anyone that likely was
not but you can you can turn this
feature on and off but it's kind of
anonymous like listening no it's it's to
say in this in this social system
identity doesn't matter it's about like
you know physicality because you blow
into the phone to make music and it's
about you know this little sense of
connection you have with someone you
know if you're like final countdown
coming from Korea I'd be like who is
that person and app gives new gives you
know answers on that but it does want
you to ask that question yeah that's
cool and is there some this probably not
a fair questions there follow-up like do
you do people make orchestras do they do
nothing this app there's no no follow-up
and I think this is a I think of as a
logical end here this is not a tool to
study kind of how people make music for
me is not a social network it's not a
social network it's it's a place where
to feel a little connected with you know
and that's that's the end
so that's in that sense amulet goes back
to this lake that's an end in itself I
just want people to feel connected it's
not here to serve another purpose beyond
that you make what I thought was a
really good point about the fact that
let's say 200 years ago but maybe even
more recently than that what families
would do in their leisure time is create
music together that's right we almost
never do that anymore we listen to music
and maybe because it's just so easy to
put it on the record or play Spotify or
whatever or Pandora I should mention
Pandora because they're they my blog my
podcast appears on Pandora now maybe
it's too easy or maybe there's a skill
or are we just exposed to really really
good musicians so far that we're
embarrassed about our own skills but you
want to kind of bring it back the
ability to get around you know at late
at night instead of watching TV we can
play music together yeah I think it goes
back to this question of meaning and
ìiíve in values I think music making to
me is a value that's something that I I
think is does a person good and and I
don't know why I think it's a probably a
lot of different factors that that's
changed kind of our relationship with
music making technology really is the
thing that's changed it for over the
last really last hundred years you know
before household electricity you know to
get music there's no broadcast there's
no internet there's no recording you had
to be where music was to listen to music
where it was made and and if you look
throughout human history there's never
been a civilization or a culture that's
been without either music or dance so
music has been with us and of course we
find like flutes made out of like bear
femur and and human bones even like kind
of dating tens of thousands of years so
you know music has has really been with
us but only really in the last hundred
to two hundred years has you know kind
of music is you know for better for well
often for the better and you know can't
be recorded it can be disseminate over
long distances and and then we can
capture like you know kind of like the
musicians that really speak to us and
we'd always have their sound and I think
that's a good part of it
perhaps possible side effect and
possible downside is that we might be
making less music than ever before and
maybe it's because I don't know I don't
I don't
I refuse to believe is because we've
hear we hear people that are like so
amazing that we are intimidated to I
think sometimes they even inspire us but
I think it's really just now we have so
much that we could do that that can you
know it's so much easier just to fire up
like a video game which I do and I love
playing or to just watch streaming video
or whatnot and all things that I love to
do yeah so they could CDs out there with
a lot of music and I don't know I'm not
I get your desire to not think that it's
because we're intimidated by people who
are better than us but I bet there's a
lot of people who used to think they
could sing and now we can listen to
Aretha Franklin and Freddie Mercury and
go well maybe I'm not as good as them or
playing the piano or whatever well I
think that's it gets back to mmm well
did this idea I think of the intrinsic
value of of making music again I think
play comes back you know you're not
making music to be good you're making
music because it like enriches you and
it's just you know to learn you know
amateur musicianship was like a good
thing you know yeah I hope it still is
because you learn an instrument for this
just because you like one you want to
know you want to learn you know and I
think the for this year intrinsic worth
of knowing how to play the piano played
the guitar and you know if you have a
favorite song you want to know to play
that song are you doing this so you can
you know be on stage performing for
thousands of people not necessarily I
think that could be that that that
that's good too but I think if you take
everything else away just making music
for yourself yeah there's some something
really awesome about that I would say
the same thing about making art right
doing dancing this is something that
most people don't do but it's not that
hard I mean you can paint you know
you'll paint badly compared to an expert
but that's okay the activity itself can
be rewarding he's
so do you think of the kinds of things
you're designing will help you bring
back the actual personal creation of
music to people I hope is to help people
realize that there's this intrinsic
value to doing this and I think what
they do I I don't know for example I
don't think the apps that the things I
do are well certainly kind of these the
apps and mobile phones they're not I
don't think of them as educational tools
at all I think of them more as like
personal expression windows like for
people to feel you want to lower the
sense of inhibition right and for people
said to feel this joy of making music to
play like in all sense of the word play
an instrument but also just play the
more things like laptop Orchestra and
things like Chuck the programming
language for music those are I think for
perhaps a different audience even though
they overlap somewhat and those are more
I think on the on a different side of
research like what kind of tools can we
build and what kind of instruments can
we build for like laptops for orchestras
of laptops and humans it tell us a
little bit about the laptop Orchestra
project it were that was there more than
one or was there yes there now they're
more than I think I would say probably
more than 70 worldwide and most women
academic institutions the first one of
its kind really started a Princeton and
while I was a grad student this was
started by my advisor Perry cook and Dan
Trueman who we still a music professor
at Princeton and they'd been exploring
kind of mmm really kind of how we can
design instruments but also design
instruments that preserve some of the
things we love about traditional
instruments one how they how they
emanate sound you know if you were to
play like a violin like in a room the
sound doesn't naturally come from a PA
system it comes from the artifact itself
and that it's a certain sense of
presence and intimacy that comes with
that kind of sound
radiant concert halls have different
feelings right it's a feeling exactly
and so they've been looking at kind of
like
different ways to build speakers that
capture the sonic intimacy and this
eventually led to the laptop Orchestra
and this started at Princeton as the
Princeton laptop Orchestra orc in 2005 I
I graduated in eight and started at
Stanford and then started the Stanford
laptop workforce lauric and the ideas
that we're in the laptop orchestra we
have computers of course we have humans
and also we have these hemispherical
speaker arrays now they look like did
you know the dome of r2d2 and they're
they actually they're made out of 11
inch diameter wooden salad bowls with
holes drilled into them and put speaker
drivers in them and whole idea is that
we sit we repair each salable with a
computer and so that the sound that the
computer's making comes out locally
together it's being played and then you
have that x 20 and you can really have a
you'll have an orchestra that can build
a wall of sound but the physical playing
is tapping on the keyboard of the
laptops
it varies we to date we've designed more
than two probably 200 different
instruments and some of them are tapping
on the keyboard uses the mouse some of
them are using things like we know it's
game controllers we've used this thing
called the game track which is like a
basically it was made to track your hand
in 3d space it was made for golf games
okay
and so it was it's tethered to this base
that's on the ground and you have work
gloves that the ends of the tethers are
attached to and that basically gives you
this just six degree freedoms of freedom
before your two hands are a little bit
theremin like you can make theremins out
of it yeah so you can you can basically
have like you can move your your arms
around your hands around and you can
translate this gesture into sonic
gestures so we anything can get our
hands on we basically can can become a
potential interface for music making in
the laptop orchestra how could I ask
another unfair question is the music
good sometimes we've been trying to make
good music sometimes it's like we always
try to make music that
interesting you know that kind of
challenges or ask some questions about
how we make music or you know this is
bring about kind of a different way you
think about creaming instrument or
performing music and certainly we you
know to the best our ability we try to
make me sex good but the music is it's
that might be a matter of taste as well
well or is it just you know first it's
remarkable you can do it at all and down
the road people will start putting it to
more artistic uses I
I think it's he's definitely exploratory
yeah we're definitely in the early
stages and but part of that I think has
to do with the medium of the computer
itself you know as a thing you make
instruments out of and Perry had this
principles like when you're designing
computer music instruments often you're
making the piece not the instrument
first and foremost okay you're kind of
figure out what you want the piece to
sounds exhausting every time you want to
make a new musical piece you have to
make new instrument actually that's
exactly that's exactly what we end up
doing is that you know we have like 200
something like 200 instruments now in
the laptop workshop we have just about
that many that many pieces and we
generally don't create general-purpose
instruments that can be used for a
number of pieces but we were think about
what is this specific piece and what is
exactly the right instrument that we can
craft to play that piece and so have
these very specialized instruments and I
think that speaks to the medium of the
computer it's possible in a matter of
days sometimes to actually have an idea
and actually prototype an instrument and
you have a piece of music that we've
never heard before and this is not
supposed to bring music making into
people's living rooms this is just
exploring a new kind of music that you
could imagine playing in a concert hall
and people coming and listening to I
think that's right yeah this is a
different way of thinking about how to
make music it's this one's left it's
less about kind of self-expression is
something like ocarina is trying to do
this one's more like researching kind of
how we make music together with this new
medium of the computer have you have to
bring collaborations with professional
composers or musicians yeah
Clark has done quite a few of these and
I mean Lorca's played with Zakir Hussain
who is the the amazing tabla player and
so percussion and they've done some
amazing things do they travel their tour
I don't know there's a tour there was
definitely a few concerts a few years
ago that featured them and it's it's
really kind of I think it's born out of
curiosity it's like how do we what kind
of instruments are possible
you know the medium is very different
it's them so you probably get different
instruments out of the medium and
because the instruments different the
music is gonna be different and the way
you perform so it's this cascading like
cause and effect you know it's designed
at every stage right you design what you
did you know it's attributed to mark
marshall mcluhan that you know the we
shape our tools and thereafter they
shape us so the laptop workers physic
the shaping things in every stage the
end result is gonna be really really
different well I was gonna ask about the
the technological aspect here the role
of Technology it you know it seems very
technological if you're making a laptop
Orchestra or an ocarina out of an iPhone
but in some sense every musical
instrument is technology right like
they've been technology all along where
I mean in what sense are we exploring
new music spaces because the technology
is allowing us to do that
well the medium that first all that's it
that's exactly right
every instrument is a technology whether
it's vibrating strings or vibrating
columns of air I think for a computer
music we're exploring the very medium of
the computer itself and the thing that
you know sets that apart perhaps from
other mediums is that one is
programmable and two in some ways I
think of traditional instruments is you
know that's really like form follows
physics yes and it but the computer you
you kind of for better fours have this
completely compartmentalized way of
thinking about instruments like what's
the input what do you want it to sound
like those can be very different and
then there's a mapping layer in the
middle then you
map the input to the output and you can
change the input without changing the
output vice versa in practice this
doesn't always work well and you wanted
to really design everything in a more we
call it a more embodied kind of a way
but that's the kind of the difference is
that this medium is something that you
know for better for us frees you from
kind of the physics the physical kind of
nature of things and into kind of rules
that are more governed and you know more
virtual realm I suppose yeah I'm
interested also you know how how much we
can formalize this right I mean there's
things you can do like so now that you
have a laptop when I was a kid kid I was
in an undergraduate this is the first
laptop era right the mid-1980s with IBM
PCs and Mac's were everywhere and I
definitely you know programmed our
little IBM pcs to make I would call them
noises more than musical sounds but it's
a very natural thing to do so then how
much once your after you've done that
can you step back and say oh here are
the principles I know you've mentioned
Cron's Berg's levels laws of technology
right I mean how intellectualized is
this versus just kind of playing around
and learning things well that's a great
question it goes actually goes broader
to this whole idea of like what design
prints what principles going to capture
about designing things in you know in
general more specifically and this is
where design and really computer music
design is is well it's it's not entirely
formalized well but I think it's more
formalized well then like it is if you
say it is right I think there's some
middle ground and if I were to go back
to Aristotle he said something like the
following we should not expect more
precision than a topic naturally a
Forte's right I can I love that quote in
your book because I was exactly thinking
that like you know should we is there
the right answer to design but Aristotle
is saying like no that's not the kind of
thing you should be looking for I think
sometimes there it's valuable to say
things you know generally or you know in
the broad sense and so design is really
in this tacit dimension in between li
you know engineering precision and
really like full formalize ability
- kind of like there is no I think there
are things we can say but they're more
like lenses to think with then like
recipes to follow right and so you know
peri for example in computer music
design had these principles you know
first one is like instant music subtlety
later is it good
he's a way to think about a pretty lower
way to think about how you design
instrument and you know he had a coffee
mug that makes music and you really pick
it up in the sensors on it enable you to
start making sound and music immediately
but over time you can learn kind of kind
of its its personality the artful way to
drink your coffee exactly so uh so it's
you know I think the principles in
artful design really was it was inspired
by kind of Perry's principle which to me
said that there is a level of
specificity in precision but only to the
extend it makes them you know make sense
and if we expect too much if we try to
formalize it too much it actually loses
something of its essence I should
mention that there are a lot of
principles in your book it's not like
three principles at the end of the book
it closes with one two three four five
six seven eight nine ten pages of
principles with like fifteen principles
for page there's a lot of principles
you'll all remember do you remember all
these no but I think when a situation
arises I it's sometimes it's a way to
think about it doesn't tell you what to
do but it gives you kind of like you
know kind of the principle automation
you know it says that there is a kind of
this membrane we can look for beyond
what you make sense to automate and on
the other side we should really be
confident about what we don't need to
automate and what we should we ought not
automate and I think so design is as
much of how to automate or how not
automate as it is figuring out where
that little boundary is and that's I
think you know really a responsibility
of the designer as well have you worked
on the automation of the composing of
the music do we have artificial
intelligence writing scores for the
laptop orchestra occasionally we have
had algorithmic components and
generative components
I think it's still a pretty open problem
and but also goes back to the question
of meanings like why do we why do we
want to do that right and and if I may I
remember this conversation had heading
to grad school and you know this is
before I went to propose all my way to
Princeton and in someone asked me what
are you do in grad school I'm like I'm
gonna computer science but I'm really
doing computer music and say okay what
do you want to do was like I want to
write like I want to I want to write a
program for the computer to generate to
make music right and and that person
asked me what's the point
an arable question and I was like yeah
that's I don't know have an answer for
that and so instead of actually it is
actually a very good question but it's a
terrible question later it's a terrible
it's a it but I think there's a it
really changed the way I think about
things and I am really glad that person
asked it because I could not answer that
because I think the meaning I realized
that you know so instead of actually
building trying to build like this like
the world's most like amazing
algorithmic composition system I went to
make a tool with which others can
actually get their hands dirty and and
build things themselves and if they want
to make an output of a composition
system they can use Chuck the
programming language to do it so I've
kind of taken one step back and designed
something like framed it completely
we're facing
it's a framing issue it reminds me a
little bit of you know in chess and go
artificial intelligence not only is
better than the best humans but comes up
with new strategies I wonder if you know
Sunday that's a much harder problem
whether artificial intelligences won't
be playing music in ways that humans
never thought up or you know kinds of
compositions we hadn't get hit on I
think I think I think it was some
somewhere in Chapter eight I think a
fellow colleague of Stanford I should I
captured this moment she asked me you
know what we have robot musicians you
know really
that play music and I seen you I said
you mean as well as humans it's like yes
and she's a philosopher so I I gave her
a kind of a tongue-in-cheek answer which
happened to believe you're so I think
you know the day we have robot musicians
is will have that day when we have robot
philosophers right and I think and she
say oh you know okay so then that means
that maybe on that day the the I will
have understood something more subtly
human and I think I think that's right
it's like oh I don't know what what that
really means but I think robots in need
to of yeah is it can comes back to the
question of meaning right well even in
the very most basic kind of pattern
recognition tasks which computers are
getting very good at it's still really
easy to fool them just by putting things
you know outside of their normal context
right right you know if you'd just saw
it this morning for some reason someone
was showing a photograph of a bus on a
road and you ask the computer what it is
and says it's a bus but then you just
like in Photoshop
rotate the bus 90 degrees and says oh
now it's a snowplow it doesn't say it
right less than 90 degrees because it
has no background framing for that and
and some things are hmm I mean for
things like you know go or chess and
image recognition there are you know
kind of what might be considered correct
answers and there are a lot of things I
think in life that we value to have no
correct answers you know like art yeah
music you know there are things that are
well that just aren't problems to be
solved so much but things will be
clearly heard about yeah right so this I
mean maybe this is not a perfect segue
but you wrote a book and number one it's
a book it's you didn't write an opera
you didn't write it up musical pieces so
you chose to write a book that's a
conscious decision and secondly it's a
graphic book right it's a not mostly
hand-drawn but photographs and overlay
text and so forth and I notice on the
cover page on the title page it says
that you go on are the author and
designer of the book so what what what
made you think that a book was the right
way to do this after all there's so much
sound
your work and there's no sound in the
book and then what made you think that
this graphic way of doing it was the
right thing that's it that's a great
question I'm still wondering that
sometimes myself but I'm really glad I
did it this way as a photo comic book
and well I think it's a book about
design so I felt like I kind of I really
wanted to very clearly and intentionally
designed it and you know the medium I
think you know design is really how you
connect the medium to the message and
this and it absolutely changes how you
write the book so it's actually I
started writing like what I thought
would be a more conventional book about
300 pages of words in text yeah it's
like this can be great what's of figures
and I thought I actually have a lot of
photos I was like you know maybe just
have more photos and figures than normal
and then it was like you know what if
there's some things it's easier to talk
about if it's talked about not so
formally but also with visual guides and
also more of like kind of a you know
conversation what if like I don't know
the pencil bag could talk you know these
things suddenly you know I don't think
about comic books that I grew up with
including the ventures of Tintin and
Chinese by the way I was in Beijing and
I was I grew up a really reading Tintin
and then you know it was like what if
half the book was was a comic book and
at that point I was like you know what
I'm sure yeah let's do that let's you
say that yeah so and then the whole
thing then was this commitment to just
it's like what what is this book really
about and now that it's and it seems to
fit the idea that what you're offering
is not the single grand unified answers
to what design is but more of a
invitation and a conversation and a set
of ideas that work together in
interesting ways right that's the hope
yes and the aim yeah I mean having
pictures of you in the book talking to
us using you know thought bubbles and
speech balloons invites a conversational
kind of response to the book yes I think
I wanted to make you feel like a kind of
a face to face conversation and and now
also I want to feel like I'm I'm I'm
there for you you know there's this like
some Ferno of design and you know kind
of and also I think it's a way to kind
of offer certain you know truths more
like in a more informal way and will
more more accessible more accessible
yeah in anyone anyone who sees a and
it's not a graphic novel it's not a
novel a graphic text what does comic
book it's a call it a comic book it a
comic photo comic book it's kind of an
interesting genre these days I
interviewed Clifford Johnson who is a
physicist a string theorist who did a
graphic novel based on physics and
string theory and there's been these
famous examples of you know graphic
novels about philosophy history and so
forth it's a growing genre it sounds
like I I think so I mean I love comic
books and one thing more I can say about
the photo fact that this is a photo
great but rather than like a drawn comic
book is that for me like you know I want
design is design me reach for the
sublime the subtitle is like technology
in search of the sublime a try to reach
for the transcendent but I think its
feet must be grounded in everyday life
you know and I think the photo aspect is
to say this is you don't have to parse
in this extra aesthetic layer of how
stylistically it's drawn but rather to
say this is I mean it has its own
aesthetic of course but these moments
happened and it's it's you know I think
it's very differently for like a comic
book of spider-man probably like I
prefer to be drawn right it's it's
fictional it's not in and that gives me
like my mind a different place to go but
aesthetically if it's not drawn but
photographs it's be very strange of like
spider-man comics for photo comics
because then you'd be wondering who's
acting a spider-man under the mask
and what's the you kind of start
thinking about the piece like but here
it's nonfiction right and you want to be
grounded you want to become real so like
every thing you're describing is a thing
you can take a picture right right and
how I mean since I'm an author I'm very
I'm kind of tempted now to write
a more graphic comic-book e physics book
but is you are the designer of the book
like how does it work what does the
actual process or you what program are
you using to make these pages I think I
horrified Ellie and pretty much everyone
that discovered how actually did this I
did this and in an old version of
OmniGraffle which is an outlining
program I was using since grad school to
make figures for my papers and I got
really there's nothing like familiarity
with nothing like minority yeah and so
every page in the book and of which
there 488 and many many pages that never
made it into the following book right
and each one of those is a separate file
in in OmniGraffle and I've learned to
you know have like a lot of these little
tools of like commonly used speech
bubbles and other things if I can
incorporate images into this kind of I
pull up those pages when I need to make
a page and and I've got I think I got
pretty at least after a year or two I
got pretty fast at doing this and it
really felt like this is yeah it feels
good I mean maybe this is a politic
question but what does Stanford think
about this the university not the press
that's I I think Stanford I don't know I
hope they like it yeah so far people
have really supported the name actually
this book was supported by both the
School of Engineering and the School of
Humanities and Sciences which to me is
like I felt like symbolically that's
awesome it's like this is actually this
is a book that is at these intersections
you know it's not it's not one or the
other but like another right right and
was it very different you know sort of
in your personal experience in the sense
that you've been doing so much music and
now you were being a visual artist in
some sense I've always been drawn to the
visual arts and also really the
combination of like the audio and visual
and interactive so and I've evolved
always taken photographs so just kind of
a hobbyist amateur photographer egg
I mean just because the audience is this
is an audio podcast you can't see it but
it's way beyond just a set of pictures
of you talking with some graphs I mean
you really obviously put a tremendous
amount of effort into the design in
terms of background images and fonts and
angles and things like that so it must
been a lot of fun it was a ton of fun it
was a ton of work and there are over
1,600 photos in the book 1,300 of which
I either took or a few of my generated
and they're like few drawings in there
and the other came from public domain
Creative Commons you know and that's
shout out I rely on Wikimedia when I
write my books it's so it's so good and
it helps you know you you in your other
design work even for the audio stuff you
also care about the visual presentation
right it's all a part of you emphasize
the human aspect of design and we're
visual creatures as much as anything
else yeah I think we're trying to I
think it's trying for design to speak to
all as much you know kind of all that we
are we're visual creatures we are
creatures I care about aesthetics that
have a sense of goodness and justice and
all of these things and so whatever
those things are that that make us who
we are I think design has this you know
potential to to address at least
something you know in the aggregate
hopefully all of that and you can an
ethical dimension where do X and
morality come in to this session for me
I think of design is like what is the
function of the thing and then what is
everything else beyond the function of a
thing you know ethics fall into for me
and to will strange to say is falls into
kind of the more of the aesthetic
dimension of design if we think of
design is simply like what are the
pragmatics and what are the aesthetics
and beam as in aesthetics and everything
beyond the sheer functionality and for
me like I think you know the ethical
dimension of design is that well I think
the argument from the book goes you know
design is all about choices you're
really just making like this cascading
series of decisions about
you know what to build how you build it
and who it's for and all of these things
and if it's all about choices then you
know and these decisions you know they
have implications for people that use
them the users in if in if that's the
case then yeah making decisions as
engineers as designers
well that's tantamount to actually
taking action you know anywhere else in
life no and if we believe that then
chinweze designers and engineers be held
at the same moral ethical framework as
as we wouldn't anywhere else and so
that's that's the argument and then the
next part of the argument is to save but
that's that just is like there's no
recipe to be moral or ethical and in
fact at least we don't agree on whether
exactly and I think that's actually that
we don't agree is why we have ethics is
that we you know values come into
conflict and we gotta try our best to
apply different lenses to this to see
how we can best in what does that even
mean to resolve it right so in some
sense this is like we said about
philosophy earlier you can't not do it
you can do it badly or you can do it
well and likewise you can't fail to have
ethical dimensions of your work when
you're designing things you can just pay
attention to them or not
that's exactly right in first law of
Kranz berg's lofts of technology taking
the technologies neither good or bad nor
is in neutral right and this has an
effect and it has an effect and you
cannot pay attention to it but it
doesn't mean it doesn't you know you
doesn't you know it doesn't have an
effect nor does that mean you're free
from responsibility you can't a company
can't say hey we've built this platform
however people use it is not our problem
you're not thinking buddy specific don't
know 99 specific companies I mean
certainly physicists historically have
done that you know we did the atomic
bomb right you know and come as chemists
and doctors these days are facing up
against the same thing that we're
recording this only a week or two after
it was announced that someone claims to
a genetically engineered a baby right
there's science there obviously but
there's clearly an ethical dimension as
well all right so I think you know for
engineers I think to really be not just
capable engineers but actually human
engineers that you've got you have to
consider all of these dimensions and you
know if you build something that's like
useful makes money but you've exploited
people or you've done harm in the
process I don't think the thing is
aesthetic is not beautiful it's not
writable right and and good thing I'll
say is I think ethics and the world
right now currently thinks of ethics
largely as this is kind of like leash on
technology but I think I would oh no I
want to offer an additional way to look
at I agree that there should be
constraints you know but what if ethics
is really like values and what if those
values are not the leash but the
foundation of what you make in the first
place like that should inform when you
build how you build it and it's much
more proactive than to say we've built
this thing how can we make sure it does
no evil right because in the end the day
no do no evil is it that's a rather low
bar I mean it's a terrible thought to
think like oh I could do all this cool
stuff if it weren't for those pesky
ethics right right it's but it's like
but if you think about it in the other
direction it's like what are my values
what are the things I find awesome and
why do I find them awesome and then you
you can get so excited about building
something and you know you've you've
kind of like and the ethical
considerations are kind of built in from
from the get-go and not as this like you
know checkpoint and that you have to
just like aesthetics you can't add as an
aesthetics not something you kind of
slap on at the end
NORs ethics some like module install
into your system just to make it ethical
and suddenly it doesn't work like that
do these do these different aspects D do
they come to your teaching at Stanford
when you talk to your students is this
part of a course on design absolutely so
I've started using the artful design in
as a textbook and in fact it's some
level I think was written as a textbook
it's a very strange textbook no
exercises I didn't see any problem sets
there's no problem sets and
there there are what I called a - it's
kind of like that people could try to do
they're not they're not you're right
they're not problem sets but they do try
to put some of the ideas into into
motion and I'm I've designed a new
course in this coming winter quarter in
2019 called design that understands us
and in this course we're actually gonna
look at the shaping of technology but
really in this full broad spectrum broad
perspective way and even here we're
gonna bring to bear really the aesthetic
dimension the ethical dimension and when
I look at everything from social network
to artificial intelligence to
instruments to toys to games to really
anything that that we find in in our
everyday lives
you say one of the things I mean maybe
to close this up meat is a good final
topic the title is artful design the
title of the book but then there's a
subtitle technology in search of the
sublime and sublime is in a different
color and underlined in it since you're
designing it this is not random choices
right why is the sublime the word you
chose there I think I think it reflects
a certain optimism you know that as
builders as engineers and engineering
itself is something that can be more
than quote-unquote simply a problem
solver that it can be something that is
beautiful truthful can be just can be
ethical and you know I think when you
talk about those things we're really
talking about kind of thesis you know
something closer to the transcendent and
for me the sublime is kind of this
window into looking at the transcendent
you know I think it's you were talking
earlier about how you know at the end of
your books you know we are just kind of
we are worth or basically these like
molecules and were these insignificant
things in this rather unremarkable like
in the grand scheme of things like rock
in series part of a solar system in this
you know
of this you know one of hundreds of
billions of galaxies and and beyond that
who knows what's out there and I think
you do you know more than I do but we
we're none of us knows very much none of
us none of us know very much but yet
we're nonzero we exist and if you think
about how small we are but also that we
actually here and we are experiencing
things I find that to be like miraculous
and that gives me and when I think about
that that's you know it's it's sublime
because it reflects a certain truth but
a truth that I also find incredibly
beautiful
well I wouldn't I mean how careful
should we be because you're using words
like sublime and transcendent and
miraculous that are often associated
with something beyond the natural world
are you you mean to imply that or is you
just taking it as part of the human
condition that is a human condition
inner feeling that is you know it's hard
to articulate but we feel it right I
think food sublime for me is that the
natural world is is that right is that
what this is this not is just like it's
insane it's like why do we why are we
there's such there's the truth out there
that we clearly do not fully understand
do you know we don't even know how to
frame it perhaps I mean like why are we
we do not understand how we come into
being or or if there's a purpose and
that's you know I mean I think you know
the universe is preposterous to quote
here you know this is it's it's but you
know really horrifying terrifying but
also in it just an exquisitely amazing
and beautiful way and I think actually
you know the natural sublime is you're
standing in front of like this huge
canyon and you feel this both a sense of
on this twinge of fear right and well I
think if you think about the universe
for example yeah I think I get both of
those feelings it's just but it's not
the kind of fear that makes you run is
the kind of makes you still you
and you makes you reflect and I think
technology you know back to technology
in search of the sublime is getting at
that same thing that I think I think for
me like the arts the humanities
fundamental you know research and
science is all trying to get at in
different ways is get at this like truth
the truth of things me and both out
there and also kind of pin ourselves
like who are we in it's so human to want
to understand ourselves just a little
bit more than before and that was
actually my question for you and I don't
know if there's an answer for this is
that I I don't really see a difference
between like what's out there what's in
here but it both seemed really hard to
do and I was gonna ask you're like
what's what's harder or is there like
even that I'm I'm very very quick to say
that physics cosmology things like that
are easier hmm anything involving human
beings because precisely the success
mode of physics and cosmology is that we
reach for the simplest manifestations of
the natural world right doesn't mean
they're easy in any objective sense
they're still hard they seem even harder
than they are because we can make so
much progress so quickly that we're led
into these abstruse realms of you know
equations and phenomena that our
everyday life does not equip us to deal
with but we can still figure it out
they're not we figured out about physics
is amazing even given how much we
haven't whereas you know we figure about
human beings is still a little bit
sketchy right complex systems are the
hard systems to understand and as far as
we know we human beings of the most
complex systems in the universe to date
okay you are you are a physicist
philosopher humanist all of that in one
well go along thank you so much for this
conversation this was great and I was
wondering if maybe we could end by you
playing us out on the ocarina if you
have a tune ready oh yeah here we don't
usually have musical accompaniment but
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]